mesdames messieurs bon dimanche il y a
un an Steven gilbaud devenait le nouveau
visage de l'environnement du
gouvernement Trudeau l'expéditant avait
la lourde tâche de faire oublier l'achat
de l'olyte transmentum de redorer le
blason vert canadien sur la scène
internationale le convaincre la
population que la tarification du
carbone les mesures de transition et des
cibles de réduction agressive pouvait
faire du Canada un leader sur la scène
mondiale mais après avoir dû autorisé le
projet baie du Nord alors que la
ministre des Finances évoque
l'importance d'accélérer le
développement des ressources pétrolières
et minières quel bilan fait le ministre
de sa première année à la tête du
ministère de l'Environnement et des
changements climatiques j'ai posé la
question à Steven gilbaud
[Musique]
vous avez jaser il y a presque un très
exactement parce que vous êtes aux
commandes du ministère de
l'Environnement et des changements
climatiques depuis un an vous avez
annoncé depuis les cibles par secteur le
plan de réduction du gouvernement vous
avez aussi approuvé du Nord et quand on
regarde les émissions canadiennes elle
stagne malgré la croissance économique
alors que chez tous nos partenaires du
G7 elle baisse pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que ça diminue moins vite ici que je
suis plusieurs de nos partenaires de ne
pas pendant 10 ans il ne s'est rien fait
c'est vrai que nous sommes au pouvoir
depuis 7 ans mais inverser infléchir la
courbe du quatrième plus grand
producteur de pétrole et de gaz au monde
ça se fait pas en criant ciseaux alors
les mesures qu'on a mis en place que ce
soit la tarification carbone depuis 2019
que ce soit les investissements
transport collectif construire un
nouveau métro ou le REM à Montréal par
exemple ça prend plusieurs donc le
déploiement des mesures demandent du
temps mais ce qu'on voit c'est que la
courbe commence à infléchir et plus on
va avancer dans le temps plus les
émissions vont dire entre le discours
quand vous faites l'annonce on a
toujours l'impression que le
gouvernement nous dit ça va ça va se
passer ça sera pas immédiat mais ça va
arriver rapidement et puis on attend et
on attend encore on le voit pas le
résultat comment je fais pour vous
croire que vous êtes ça va se passer ça
arrive bien je vous donnerai l'exemple
des véhicules électriques par exemple
dont la vente a doublée ou presque
depuis au cours des deux dernières
années on a déployé 25000 bornes de
recharge rapide déjà au cours des trois
dernières années au Canada on va
déployer 50000 de plus dans les deux
dernières années à date de deux
prochaines années pardon alors on voit
que clairement
en Colombie-Britannique on est rendu à
presque 20% des ventes de de nouveaux
véhicules sont des véhicules électriques
au Québec on est à 14 15%. donc on voit
que ça commence ça commence à
fonctionner
mais mais il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de travail à faire et ça je
suis le premier reconnaître 40-45 d'ici
2030 carburant neutralité d'ici 2050
vous en avez toujours convaincu votre
patron monsieur Trudeau a dit encore
cette semaine la semaine dernière que
c'était encore sa cible à lui qu'est-ce
qui pourrait arriver qui pourrait vous
faire manquer cette cible de là
honnêtement on n'a pas on n'a pas
beaucoup de choix dans les trois
dernières années on a connu les feux de
forêt les plus les plus meurtriers et
les plus les plus économiquement dans ma
jambe de l'histoire du pays les
inondations les plus coûteuses de
l'histoire du pays et maintenant la
tempête tropicale la plus coûteuse de
l'histoire du Paypal dans les 30
dernières années pendant les 10
dernières années dans les trois
dernières années nous sommes entrés dans
l'ère des changements climatiques et
plus ça va aller si on ne fait rien plus
ça va faire mal plus ça va coûter cher
plus il y a des vies qui vont être
perdus des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui vont être affectées par ça
nous avons une obligation de résultats
vous avez évoqué la quelques jours
quelques semaines la le fait que
ces phénomènes naturels là vont imposer
des déplacements de Canadiens vous allez
que certains Canadiens allaient de voir
se faire à l'idée qu'il devrait changer
déménager déplacer leur maison ça a pas
été très très très bien accueilli
partout cette déclaration là
l'idée c'est pas de forcer les gens
parce que c'est responsable
de permettre à des gens de retourner
dans des zones que l'on sait à être
inondable quand les inondations
arrivaient une fois par 100 ans
qui arrivaient une fois où s'entend
arrive maintenant aux deux trois ans
alors c'est pas un problème théorique
que j'ai inventé monsieur Legault le
Premier ministre le goût lors des
dernières vagues d'inondations dans
l'ouest de Montréal le gouvernement de
la carte a dit la même chose on a
remboursé des gens pour les dommages
liés à ces inondations là mais on a dit
aux gens si vous retournez là vous savez
que vous êtes dans une zone à risque on
ne remboursera pas la prochaine fois
alors je pense que c'est une réflexion
globale qu'on doit avoir et c'est une
responsabilité moi je pense que c'est
irresponsable et même immoral de
permettre à des gens de continuer d'être
dans des zones que l'on sait être à
risque que ce soit les feux de forêts
les inondations ou les tempêtes
tropicales je sais que qui disait la
semaine dernière le Canada doit et va
faire preuve de générosité en faire ses
alliés en accélérant par exemple la
réalisation de projets énergétiques et
minier dans nos alliés ont besoin pour
chauffer leur maison fabriquer des
véhicules électriques qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça pour vous ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'on a un régime
d'évaluation environnementale et de
consultation publique qui est très
rigoureux au Canada est-ce qu'on peut
faire mieux je pense qu'on peut toujours
faire mieux ça veut dire quoi faire
mieux par exemple il y a il y a trois
éléments qui vont faire que des projets
l'évaluation de projet peut être peut
être tardé des promoteurs qui sont mal
qui sont mal préparés et qui arrivent en
évaluation d'impact avec avec des
dossiers tout crush de mauvaises
consultations ou pas de consultation du
tout avec les peuples autochtones et
leurs ça sera mars devant les tribunaux
pendant des années et toute la question
des espèces en péril alors nous ce qu'on
peut faire au niveau de l'évaluation
environnementale c'est travailler avec
les entreprises les promoteurs pour être
certain que quand ils arrivent ils
soient bien préparés ça veut dire quoi
ça fait quoi la différence prendre la
main d'un promoteur puis l'aider
préparer son dossier sans ça ça peut
retrancher combien de temps à
l'évaluation environnementale d'un
projet mal ficelés par des promoteurs
prendre 10-12 ans à être évalué alors
que la procédure normale selon les
projets là mais grosso modo ça peut se
faire en trois quatre ans il y a une
différence monstres entre trois quatre
ans versus 10-12
cette semaine qui parlait une situation
géopolitique changeante un peu partout à
travers le monde et qui laissait en tant
que il y avait urgence d'agir 3-4 ans
c'est pas très urgent ça
je pense que de ne pas les Canadiens
croient beaucoup à l'importance de ces
processus là et je pense que la
meilleure façon de faire en sorte que
des projets prennent beaucoup de temps
c'est d'essayer de couper les cohérents
d'une part d'autre part je pense que nos
partenaires sont bien conscients de ce
qu'on peut faire pour eux à court moyen
long terme lorsque le chancelier
allemand est venu passer une semaine au
Canada et pas venu ici pour pour savoir
ce qu'on pouvait faire pour lui la
semaine prochaine savoir ce qu'on peut
faire pour lui dans les trois quatre
prochaines années mais aussi dans les 20
prochaines années dans les 30 prochaines
années les conservateurs vous accusent
de surtaxer les Canadiens en pleine
inflation
même d'une récession en début d'année
prochaine est-ce que ça vous rend le
travail plus difficile quand vient de
temps convaincre les Canadiens que votre
plan il est essentiel d'une part au
Québec le système fédéral ne s'applique
pas pour la tarification carbone le
Québec le Québec à son propre système
qui qui est différent et là où le
système fédéral s'applique le
directeur parlementaire du budget a dans
un rapport récent réaffirmer que 8
familles sur 10 dans ces provinces-là
reçoivent plus d'argent de la
tarification carbone fédérale que ce que
ce que cela rencontre d'autre part les
changements climatiques coûtent au
canadiens au Canadien des milliards des
dizaines de milliards de dollars et
selon une étude récente du Conseil
canadien du climat en 2025 pendant 2050
en 2025 les coûts annuels des
changements climatiques au Canada seront
de l'ordre de 25 milliards de dollars
par année Québec troisième lien est-ce
qu'il y a une option d'après vous peut
être
réconciliable avec le transport des gens
là-bas et la lutte aux émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
ce que j'ai dit sur cette question là
est-ce que nous avons dit depuis
longtemps c'est que l'augmentation du
réseau routier est incompatible avec la
lutte au changement climatique même si
de plus en plus les véhicules que qui
seront sur nos
on travaille sur un règlement pour que
100 % des nouvelles ventes de véhicules
en 2035 soit des véhicules 0 émissions
vous achetez une voiture en 2034 les
gens les gardent
alors c'est pas vrai qu'un 2030 en 2034
100% des véhicules sur nos routes vont
un des véhicules électriques c'est pas
une bonne idée
nous attendons toujours les études du
gouvernement du Québec lorsqu'il y aura
lorsqu'il y aura des études nous allons
regarder ça et faire une évaluation du
projet mais vous partez vous semblez
partir au départ en disant c'est
difficile pour moi de voir une façon
pour lequel ce projet-là serait
acceptable environnemental ce que j'ai
dit c'est qu'il y aurait des évaluations
c'est un projet qui va traverser le plus
grand cours d'eau au pays il y a des il
y a des espèces menacées dans le fleuve
il y a des impacts sur la qualité de
l'eau il y a des impacts sur l'étalement
urbain aussi bien sûr notamment sur la
sur la rive sud de Québec où on trouve
certaines des meilleures terres
agricoles alors que tout le monde est
préoccupé par la question de la sécurité
alimentaire présentement donc il y aura
il y aura un impact mon rôle est un peu
celui d'un arbitre dans ce processus là
donc il y a l'agence d'évaluation
environnementale qui fait des
évaluations d'impact et qui me fait des
recommandations et l'engagement que nous
avons pris c'est de respecter ces
recommandations là même je vous dirais
quand ça fait pas mon affaire sur baie
du Nord je pense que les gens
comprennent que j'ai reçu une
recommandation favorable de cette agence
vous allez pas ça faisait pas mon
affaire mais on avait pris l'engagement
de les écouter donc sur le troisième
lien ce sera la même chose c'est une
ville bon merci beaucoup merci à vous